-Finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we
should post on Twitter, okay?
I'm going to show
you five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Did you get them there?
I can just tell by the confusion
that, yes, it is working.
Now, you can all vote for --
Why is everyone
looking left and right?
You have them now, right?
Okay?
Wow. Okay, here we go.
You can all vote for...
People are still
going like this.
Either you have it or you don't.
Okay, here we go.
You can vote for
all of them, okay?
That's the fun of the game.
You can vote for all of them,
whatever you want,
and we'll see the results live.
Or you can vote for
none of them,
if you don't feel like
doing this.
You can just go,
"Jimmy, you do the work.
I'm not doing the work for you.
Yeah."
Roots, you have clickers,
as well.
-Yep.
-Yes, we do.
-How correct have you been,
Tariq, on these?
-Oh, I'm always spot on.
-You know which one
is going to be tweeted.
-Absolutely. Yeah.
-Quest?
-I'm 50/50.
-Yeah.
-I know which ones they are,
but we didn't rehearse it,
so The Roots do not know.
And I think I know
which one it is, too,
but I've been pretty good.
I think I've nailed it.
-Uh, not so much.
-You have no idea which one --
what I'm voting for
or what I'm doing or --
It's all -- It's private.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show,
and you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it from home.
Thank you.
It's a shared experience.
You guys -- Are you guys ready
to have some fun?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, here we go.
The first tweet is...
Alright. Alright. Wow.
♪♪
Uh...I like that,
but I feel like the audience is,
like, tepid on that one.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Alright, there you go.
It was, yeah, like almost 50/50,
but, yeah, it was a non-tweet.
Here we go.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
Thank you, Damon.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here's the next one.
The next one is...
♪♪
"You don't think
I can handle that?
You don't think I can handle a
little bump and grind?"
Let's see --
Let's see the results.
Here we go.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's a goodie.
That's a good one.
"Yeah, you don't trust me?
Come on. I can do it."
Alright, next one here.
♪♪
Okay.
Let's see the results
on that one.
Yeah!
♪♪
You have to, right?
Yeah, yeah.
You calling it right now?
-No, I was wrong on that one.
-You were?
-Yeah.
-Oh, wow. Interesting.
I would be
a little disappointed.
He has to do that, right?
Yeah. Next up.
♪♪
Oh, don't -- You're playing
the theme wrong.
You're not even playing
the waiting theme.
Yeah. At least give it --
Give it a fighting chance.
You start playing
depressing music after it,
what are they supposed to do?
It's like when "The Brady Bunch"
had a serious --
♪ Womp, womp, wa-na ♪
No, it's corn cones, man.
I'm thumbs-upping it
right now, man. Corn cones.
I want to see that happen.
Kellogg's, you hearing me?
Let's see the results.
Oh, my...
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
Oh, my God.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my -- Oh, my gosh.
I've never seen
that result ever.
-Yeah.
-And I voted "yes" for you.
-Our audiences are
on the same page tonight.
-I think I may have
doubled or tripled down on it.
-No, it doesn't matter.
You can only vote once.
Alright, the last one here
for "WeTweet."
This last one is...
♪♪
That's pretty funny.
"Hey, I'm a hot-tub guy.
Hey, don't worry about it."
"What does your husband do?"
"I'm a hot-tub guy. What's up?
Let's get in there, man.
Let's...
Let's touch kneecaps
and see what's up.
Don't worry about it, man.
We all got it, right?
Come on, man.
Let's have fun
in this hot tub, man.
Rub-a-dub-dub."
-Rick. His name's always Rick.
-His name's always Ricky?
-Right.
-"Ricky The Hot-Tub Guy."
Alright, let's see
the results on that jam.
Oh, not bad!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Whoa!
That's the winner right there.
[ Dinging ]
That's it!
I will post this during
commercial break.
Thank you for helping me out,
helping us out.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet," and enjoy.